[Music]
we feelings for saying to school you
nervous actually doc it hopeless and I
don't enjoy the things that I want to
love where are you getting this from
there's a logical martial obviously
there's a really sweet guy my yoga [ __ ]
really disappointed for five months
Charles birthday so I'd like to offer to
buy you drinks really manager can he ask
for IDs here by the way I'm definitely
old enough to drink alcohol feed you
obviously I just always act out and
everything looks like my own first only
review I just go a walk
he's not just reel it back to normal
did you wash this a good but only
because I was doing a load and since my
30 hurry up you guys
please guys doing home I've had manova
taking your school or acting weird
oh my god thank you very much for
everything
misses some and you are
I like the Dante but they're dead broke
so I thought they could stay here
hey here try looking at this as
something that could be sort of exciting
okay guys let's just see where abouts
knots to grab each other stop ah I want
you to grab that and close down toilet I
don't know your ex but he must be some
kind of mania whoever let you slip
through his hands
I'm 48 I like bold oh my god tell me Sam
- what are you doing you just can't
think straight is that one on he forgot
about your play let me stay for it daddy
when is it again
Nicky buddy
[Music]
you need to decision about your life
when you're 25 years old you think
that's a good life decision ever the
rest of your life seems to be handling
everything really well
okay you looky
[Music]
it's gonna be gay oh okay
you